did you ever follow up on the guy that
was running or training for the olympics
that got voted for so that this is a
story that appeared on laura ingraham
where a guy who was training for the
olympics got called by what's the voter
integrity fund the guy
matt brainer oh yeah okay yeah what
happened with that so they call
this dude his name is nashon garrett
he's training for the olympics in
tennessee he's from arizona but he moved
there
five months ago changed his address
voted in tennessee because
he's going to be in the olympics his
this guy is is not some random dude who
got a phone call this guy's got a
wikipedia entry he's a he's a well-known
collegiate wrestler he's like apparently
like really good
so he appeared on laura ingram he said
he got a phone call from the voter
integrity fund asking if he had
requested a mail-in ballot in arizona
well no of course not i'm in tennessee
did you vote
no i voted in tennessee boom so
i'm interviewing i'm interviewing matt
brainard again on thursday oh cool they
told me
i talked to his people today they told
me they've got a lot of stuff to report
they're feeling very good about their
results i don't know if it's going to be
hundreds of thousands
or whatever but you know if it's 10 20
30. you get guys like this a problem a
free certificate
legit person yeah definitely a prominent
yeah that's you know he's got a
wikipedia page man for his
but look there's there's standards not
that wikipedia is a good
the best source especially right now but
there are standards for what qualifies
this guy is a college wrestler who's won
a bunch of things and generated press
because of it
and he's going to be in he's training
for the he's going to be in the olympics
yeah i'm assuming
yeah so this is like this goo this is
the kind of guy that could be on
on a wheaties box we had that thing on
twitter just a couple of days ago
the whole maiden gate and i don't know i
don't know enough about that though but
and it was like just turning on twitter
it was uh
um this one kind of like activist
journalist found that like if you're a
woman and then
if you were previously married in
another state in this whole situation
and it's
it's just compiling so i'm careful with
that stuff
yeah i i am true too much random
yeah but more importantly if if we see
on the voter integrity fund they're
doing phone calls right this is
they've already reported they've found
thousands like in each state of people
who changed their addresses to different
states
but still voted here's the crazy thing
so so this is the kind of thing where
it's like we have
definitive proof tweets i can't really
do much with right but check this out
if this dude naishon uh nashan garrett i
think yeah right
if he didn't vote and he's publicly
saying wasn't me
somebody voted in my name and it wasn't
me think about all of these these
numbers because matt brainard said they
found
like 8 000 10 000 14 000 in each of
these states
you may have moved because of covid but
then they still because you're still
registered and it was only a few months
ago you moved right right so the mailing
ballot comes to your mailbox
somebody sends it in but this is the
crazy thing is that somebody said you
had to request it
nevada i believe was the only swing
state that was universal mail in ballots
where
they just sent them all out california
too they just sent them all out and they
and
the courts just ruled against news i'm
saying he wasn't allowed to do that yeah
i just interviewed uh
kevin kiley who was the republican uh
lawmaker in california's really fighting
news it seems like he's getting a lot of
momentum and you know we'll see what
we'll see what happens with with all
that but um okay at least we have
someone in california sticking up
here here let's put one thing to rest
it is obvious seeing how sydney powell
has mobilized
seeing how linwood is mobilized seeing
how brainerd has mobilized seeing how
there's a giant crowdsourcing effort
underway none of them were prepared for
this beforehand
yeah there is no credence to any story
that trump has laid some trap and that
he was
mega prepared and he had all this lined
up and was ready to go
zero because the people who are doing
the work right now
should have been if there was should
have been contacted before
should have been prepared brainerd had a
vacation scheduled with his wife and
family he had to cancel it i'm supposed
to say this jeff his wife was really mad
i know but you know what turn on news
i'm keeping it real you know i'm keeping
it real
and like you know that's that's that's
on brand for me
and so like but that isn't there that
wasn't there that that pre-work wasn't
there that's not to say this isn't real
but this wasn't a trap so what you're
saying is don't trust the plan
and what you're saying is that they
didn't really know in advance
i've heard i've heard too much where i'm
like dude they think trump's playing you
know 12th dimensional chess
it's full on string theory for trump you
know m theory
no look man they've got their plans they
say they're they're getting evidence i
say
bring it on i look forward to seeing it
but i'll tell you this
it's it comes and goes in waves a bit
right so i they announced the biden wins
and i'm like wow i guess is that it is
that
no one saying anything i'm like i guess
they're calling it for biden but then
all of a sudden we start seeing these
weird things pop up sworn affidavits
whistleblower from the post office
uh poll watchers are saying i can't see
anything
and it starts to get weird like oh maybe
trump might have something
now we're seeing that the supreme
court's not going to take up one of his
his
one of his claims a bunch of other
civilian citizen lawsuits got thrown out
and it's hard to know exactly if trump's
gonna be able to pull something you know
pull off this like
last ditch hail mary but then you get
this story about this this clark county
commission i
have to imagine trump's lawyers are
immediately filing full speed like
throw the whole thing out it's 153k
votes but i'll tell you what the
craziest thing was
when i woke up this morning it was
actually last night i think i saw the
story but this morning
the story donald trump drops key claim
from his lawsuit
that 700 000 ballots were compromised by
a lack of poll watching and i went
wow okay i saw that i saw this i said
that's it
that's that was that's the only way
trump wins pennsylvania
he's dropping this from his suit well
certainly trump must be done right
turns out it was a lie like washington
post just straight up lied
and politico wrote politico check the
political wrote this story saying
trump drops key claim from lawsuit or
pulls back and i'm reading it's like now
that trump is no longer going after this
claim
he won't be able to flip enough votes to
win pennsylvania and then i open the
lawsuit
and i go to the rudy giuliani tweets
about he says go read it it's in there
it's all in there they didn't take any
of it out
why did politico washington post daily
mail all of these outlets just publish
like the most insanely fake news i've
ever seen
listen i read fake news i see it all the
time
what they do is framing devices because
they want to make sure they can say oh
well actually
you look at covington right the
covington kids on the stairs of the
lincoln memorial
and you've got this video and you say
well there was a video so we thought it
was correct
that's how they try and get away with it
this story you could literally just
read the the document and it says there
was not meaningful access
682 000 votes were cast without access
so they're calling for
pa to be they're calling for injunctive
relief to stop the certification process
because there is no other meaningful
relief you can't throw the ballots out
what do we do it was in violation of the
of the election code in pennsylvania
i wonder why did all of these outlets
come out and claim
trump gave up trump's dropping the key
component that's it he's got nothing
left it's over
is it to try and convince people that
trump is not going to pull this off is
that trump is losing
i'll tell you this to quote michael
malus if they weren't losing
they wouldn't the pro let me try again
if they weren't losing the propaganda
wouldn't be necessary exactly that's
what michael said
yes now of course propaganda they always
use it but i gotta tell you man
this is the freakiest thing to read an
art to read all of these articles from
all these different news websites
straight up fake but dude dude dude
the the tax story right right it says
like
750 dollars paid but then you read
the actual article and even down at the
bottom it's like
oh yeah trump actually pre-paid 5.6
amount of millions of millions of
dollars basically made an interest-free
loan
to the federal government and at this
point didn't have to pay because he had
already
paid but listen there but they don't
ever talk about the headlines right
right so so
the new york times puts out this story
about donald trump's taxes never
verified it
we have no idea if they actually have
any tax documents trump says they don't
it says in the beginning trump only paid
750
then like you said you go down it says
actually trump paid 1 million in 2016
and 4 a 4.2 in 2017
as you know as a holdover for potential
liabilities
that trick is a framing device okay so
so so
that's not on the on the level we're
seeing right now what they did was
they're like well
he he paid he only well we meant he paid
his bill of 750.
but he did pay so they're doing a
semantic argument right yeah
with this over trump's lawsuit they come
out and they were like hey everybody
trump gave up
trump trump gave up his lawsuit's over
he can't win anymore are they news
guarded
yes all of them of course they are with
all of us
of course absolutely not because yes yes
this is crazy yo we should build a
fact-checking network like you've been
talking about but also a context
checking network
when you does it when they show videos
and if it's only like a 17 second be
like this is not
this is missing yes yes but this is so
awesome the bigger question here is
how could this possibly be negligence
when all you have to do is click the
document
from trump from his website and scroll
down it took me
a minute and i read i read uh rudy
giuliani tweets read paragraphs 132 to
150 and i'm like okay
and i clicked it and i read it and i'm
like sounds like sounds like they're
saying
100 or 682 000 votes were uh
counted without watchers in violation of
election code and
thus there's no meaning for a leaf other
than injunction makes sense then i look
at all these articles and i'm i'm i'm
second guessing myself
because i'm thinking what am i getting
wrong here what what am i missing on
this
how could all of these outlets say this
was there a technical thing like he was
he withdrew a motion for x not like
they're actually taking why
politico politico straight up said by
dropping this
trump will no longer be able to overturn
enough votes to claim pennsylvania got
it
i mean that's interesting he wasn't even
trying to he was calling for us to free
certification right an injunction
i saw a headline our front page was
either new york times washington post
that says like
something something something despite no
evidence of fraud
none zero zero zero not caveated not
widespread not
anything and this is this is why it's
impossible to talk to your old friends
this is why it's impossible
to go on facebook and talk to people you
knew from high school because they
dude cnn new york times seems legit
washington post
team's legitimacy tim you we literally
have a a part of the country who
looks at trump as like little literally
hitler
this guy's literally hitler so i mean i
don't
i don't know how where we go forward i
just feel bad for them
for these people because they've been
brainwashed just like i said last time
on here they've been beaten over the
head they've been abused
they've been tortured by their own party
and now they're just dancing they're
like little scared
marionettes yeah like that that one
journalist from uh
yeah from that one journalist from cnn
and she just did like uh her whole
monologue on how
trump is basically hitler and we're
living in oh yeah christianity yeah
i'm in poor in nazis i remember when i
thought she was
the most like legitimate authentic
you could trust her no no no no dude
dude the prime minister from israel
literally told her like you better
actually apologize thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you